Oh  [Music]  oh yeah hi hi I'm Mike I've never really  actively whoever I thought to be pretty  cool you really really want to be a part  of your movie bright it's just a great  film and reminds me a lot of alienation  I love right if you guys think a sequel  I really hope that you can include me in  it I can do some action could be joel  edgerton stand in view of hard earth  great a process even I can play dead  Will Smith oh wow in honor honestly she  just work was Will Smith that would make  my life trying to get Gaiman Zapata  making turn to what be eat your bottle  receive justice an opponent so properly  unleashing the bus I what got the new  job if you guys play shadow run we could  play together  [Music]